emanuel marco anunció que francia
volverá a estar bajo confinamiento a
partir de este viernes un confinamiento
que durará al menos hasta el primero de
diciembre él hizo un diagnóstico de la
situación diciendo que están sumergidos
por la rapidez con la que se ha
expandido esta segunda ola que es mucho
más mortífera y mucho más dura que la
primera que se vivió durante la
primavera una situación que no solamente
está viviendo francia sino también todos
los países vecinos y para esto se
necesita una estrategia nacional que sea
un punto medio entre la salud y la
economía con este confinamiento volverán
a cerrar los restaurantes y también los
bares estarán prohibidos los
desplazamientos entre las diferentes
regiones así como las reuniones públicas
y privadas habrá que volver al trabajo
desde casa de manera generalizada y pues
para salir a la calle solamente podrá
ser para comprar alimentos o para ir al
médico todo esto con un justificativo en
mano lo que sí permanecerá abierto los
servicios públicos las escuelas los
colegios las guarderías se podrán hacer
visitas a los residentes a las
residencias de personas mayores y
también podrán
se acabó los funerales el presidente fue
muy enfático en decir que las medidas
barrera deben continuar no solamente en
la esfera pública sino también en lo
privado cuando se esté en familia con el
uso de tapabocas todas estas medidas van
a ser detalladas este jueves en la tarde
cuando ron castex el primer ministro
pues de una conferencia de prensa el
gran objetivo del gobierno es pasar de
40 mil casos diarios a 5000 casos
diarios todo esto con la esperanza de
poder celebrar navidad en familia